i'm determined to get out of this room
we're doomed it's not gonna happen maybe
we can just shoot al capone with us if
you don't give us the code i'm gonna
have you dead i want your family dead
we're just completely screwed we're so
bad at this give me another clue or i'll
do it i'll do it
[Music]
so matt
do you have any idea what we're doing
right now i honestly have no idea the
producers they're going to send us on an
adventure they got us a car they said
it's a nice car i'll agree to anything
that they asked me to do this like if
it's three weeks in advance or more and
they say you're gonna go to do this
thing in three weeks yeah i'll just
agree to it yeah and then the day comes
and the day comes like oh crap i got to
do that thing all right i'm in i'm
excited you're known for your enthusiasm
let's see the car where's the car
oh wow
oh man oh wow is that like a late 90s
civic
car i don't
oh no it's a tesla wait a second well
okay let's see i uh i learned how to
drive in new york yeah i've only had
probably six or eight points on my
license in my life i have four points so
i'm good all right you're right i'll
think i'll take it
this is gonna be a very basic question
how do i open it where's the handle yeah
i don't oh oh man i'm in the future i
guess if we were really the future it
would open straight up but this is still
pretty impressive
yeah this is way too quiet that's that's
my problem should we just blast some
gangsta rap or something
if i know how to do that
it's the mother sucking m-a-t-t matt
walls matt walsh you know
let me ask you this
you're driving with your wife
yeah
are you always the one driving i'm 100
of the time
any man i see
in the passenger seat
with a female driving i make all the
judgments i can't about them based only
on that you know there have been a
couple times when friends of ours
have been over and the wife or the
girlfriend is driving yeah and my wife
has actually told me she's like hey you
gotta you gotta talk to someone so you
gotta tell him that's not that's not
good that's not how god intended it to
be
she's got a good head on her shoulder
she's got a good head on her shoulder
have you ever done an escape room
i was gonna say i actually think that's
what we're doing i did an escape room
with uh ben shapiro and uh
i couldn't do anything but he solved all
the riddles there's a whole there's like
um okay uh the idea for instance that um
it wouldn't be pee pee pee poop and then
you're just done in like five minutes
exactly i just
sat there and he did everything so if
this is an escape room the only thing
you're gonna get from me
is a
occasionally witty banter with whoever
the actor or actress is and that's about
it i'm not that'll keep morale up but
it's not going to get us out it's not
going to get us out of that yes
and we are at an escape room
[Music]
hey guys oh hey welcome to trapped it's
very nice to meet you i can't wait to
escape yeah well we'll see we are a
family run and operated business we have
two different locations one in nashville
and one in pigeon forge tennessee are we
all ready to get started can't wait okay
awesome so you have 60 minutes to escape
with your group you have three clues
that you can use at any point so you're
going to be in our capone room this one
is kind of our middle of the road it'll
be good for just two people to go
through
all right so right this way guys
come on in this is capone's apartment
just bringing you back memories
yeah going back as a kid a little back a
lie christmas time yep are you all ready
i'm really nervous i'm terrified
determined okay good luck okay have fun
[Music]
the year is 1927.
chicago is being run by the most
notorious gang leaders history has ever
known lawlessness rules the day as most
of the police force is on the tank you
have been falsely accused of being an
informant to the fbi al capone the
founder and boss of the chicago mob has
had you captured and held in his
apartment and is returning to settle the
score in one hour now's your only chance
to escape before scarface returns
okay all right so we've been left in al
capone's apartment yeah unattended
they've told us exactly what he's going
to return to kill us so i've only you
know i've only done one of these but i
remember you just kind of like
you just try to like find stuff you want
to find like piece of paper or something
you know
like is this a clue so it's
well it could be that could be like a
like a code yeah
what is the objective to open one of
these doors yeah like i assume to get
out of there right well you know what we
need
to keep
smiling at me
there's no time for something never saw
the sun
[Music]
this phone has to be something
[Music]
you're way too relaxed about the fact
that
everyone's gonna come kill us i know oh
wait this is something star dust of a
song this is obviously okay important
my dearest
alphonse
stay safe my love and i know that you
are always in my heart so here's stars
in my eyes
i heard a forest praying the trees were
cold and bare
what was the forest saying let me repeat
there
what was the forest saying
we are so bad at this
auditing theory and practice
so we ask for a clue already like i
guess that's kind of embarrassing this
is already on film so there's no
escaping there's no escape embarrassment
so if you wanted a clue who would ask i
think you could probably pick up that
phone
[Music]
geez hello khloe
[Music]
wait it's
ringing does not exist
please check the number and dial it
again
is this phone part of the thing or am i
i don't know you might have just called
the wrong number
oh yeah i found like a weird nerf gun or
something oh there we go that's
something maybe we can just shoot al
capone with this
that's that's that's a thing that's
gotta be yeah that's a thing okay
left it there by accident yeah
there's a lock on this one hold on oh
yeah kid
now we're cooking now we're cooking i
don't know what hit him
it'll be a nerf gun that hits him
[Music]
nice
let's just get another clue yeah
huckabee is going to come kill us uh
clue
[Music]
have you tried placing the record oh
dating forward it's pretty smart
i feel like a dummy there's a flashlight
in that in that clock there we go there
we go oh yeah kid so the clock says
eight days
we should just call berlin asking you to
be like hey ben
oh what if it's this number
no
we've been better off with the cigar bar
i think we would have we would have been
better at it that's for sure
do you know this thing quest to 84.99
looks a lot more expensive than that it
looks like i was gonna say much cheaper
this phone has to be like a thing yeah
type in 84.99
oh oh man we're stupid give me that
flashlight
so dumb oh man i feel like a dummy
yeah michael you dummy
let's see
there we go yeah kid there we go oh yeah
notice how we're talking we're still
just as stuck as we were
that's too
it bad you i think so i don't know if
it's gonna help us escape but yeah yeah
see you're gonna give us the code see
if you don't give us the code i'm gonna
have you dead i want your family dead i
want your house burned to the ground i
want to go to the ground i want to piss
on the edges
that cause that break anything loose in
your head no i was hoping they'd come in
they'd be so intimidated by i guess
[Music]
okay so you've got franklin morrow and
montgomery
franklin
morrow and montgomery
franklin or the franklin library
okay
oh here we go phone number
[Music]
girlfriend
i saw him take you into his apartment
but then i saw him leave just now
without you
you gotta get out of chicago as fast as
you can
[Music]
so let's watch just five minutes faster
yeah so then it's 10
30 7.
let's see that doesn't mean
douglas park
wait a second
[Music]
a very similar shoe collection
all right
[Music]
wow that's impressive
so there's a lock on there's no way
we're just completely screwed
we're going to do this
[Laughter]
i thought we won
[Music]
all right well there's a chest here
i'm i'm experiencing real shame about
how stupid i am at this moment yeah we
have to have stuff from this room bring
it into that room oh
do you have a flashlight
uh i put it somewhere oh here we go
here's another flashlight oh
so here's one
[Music]
two
okay
yeah so we got number
six
three
four
now it only has three
[Music]
no that this worked
oh wow we found the guns and the money
there you go
oh we got a bunch of stogies too all
right let's turn around all right so we
got that
so stogies
six money
two guns how many stogies
three
four five six seven eight nine
nine
nine
six two that's that's one of them
there we go
elsewhere in the room these names can be
found try looking at objects that are
usually bound
the
letters are key to finding three names
so the letters that are depressed are
just q and a i think
match the dates with the names find the
dollars and cents
now we have five and a half minutes left
it's not gonna happen
i mean we're doomed to this point it's
like a hopeless
it's hopeless no one here gets out alive
there we go
all right
look at this
oh yeah kid all right redemption here we
go
okay
oh the time douglas park 355.
departure arrival time
dude
[Music]
i think that was a record i'm so glad i
didn't have to take that cyanide pill
that was very impressive if i would say
so myself do we get a t-shirt do we win
a prize do we we can definitely work
something out okay were you watching us
the whole time yeah yeah uh who would
you say did a better job
between yeah
yeah no comment on that
but wow if you had to judge based on who
focused more rather than dancing yeah
okay
you know that i'd say
dead to rights
thanks for coming thank you thank you
for having us i'm glad that we got out
[Music]
you